michel fabbro je vous remercie d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
après un an de révolte
quel bilan faites vous qu'est ce qui a
changé concrètement dans la vie de le
gagner aujourd'hui
bonjour je pense que le bilan est mitigé
parce qu'en fait il ya des la révolution
a obtenu quelques avancées en même temps
a connu quelques échecs haut niveau donc
de ce qu'elle a pu obtenir il ya le
débat y avait plusieurs tabous qui ont
été brisés sur ces différents sujets
comme par exemple la laïcité aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup de libanais qui adhèrent
à ce concept de laïcité de mariage civil
le président de la république lui-même à
réclamer un état laïque
il ya également la citoyenneté
aujourd'hui les libanais demande des
comptes à leurs députés alors ministre à
leur président à leurs responsables
politiques et il ya également en fait le
l'audit juricomptable qui a été réclamé
par la population pour en fait demandé à
ce que les fonds qui ont été volés qui
ont été sujets à la corruption puisse
être rapatrié
maintenant au niveau des échecs il y en
a quand même des échecs importants par
exemple
en fait les révolutions été
essentiellement d une révolution de
jeunes et 7
en fait les jeunes ont continué à
émigrer il ya également en fait
l'absence de projets communs au sein de
l'arène des groupes révolution est donc
ya pas eu de projet d'alternance qui a
pu être présenté ensuite le pays est en
fait il faut pas l'oublier est une
démocratie parlementaire
donc le parlement ce sont les partis le
président du parlement c'est le chef
d'un parti c'est même la personnalité la
plus forte du pays l'accusé lui-même
d'être à la tête d'une mafia à la mafia
des générateurs qui empêche
l'électricité au liban c'est lui qui
décide de l'ordre du jour donc les
projets de lois qui peuvent être votée
les projets de loi qui ne peuvent pas
être votée donc par exemple les projets
de loi qu'il souhaite faire voter c'est
le projet sur la loi d'aministie des
géantistes et trafiquants de drogue
mais en même temps les projets le wat
qu'il bloque et que la population
réclame c'est l'indépendance de la
justice
alors justement concernant la crise
politique au liban on l'a vu ces
derniers temps trois premiers ministres
ont démissionné le 1er c'était saad
hariri aujourd'hui cet ancien premier
ministre libanais est pressenti pour
revenir au pouvoir
comment est-ce que réagissent justement
les libanais à ça en fait saad hariri
comme vous dites et elle a fait la
population l'a poussé à démissionner dès
le 29 octobre 2019 aujourd'hui il c'est
parce que comme je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure ce sont les partis qui dirige le
pays à travers le moc assise
parlementaire s'est il souhaite la
plupart d'entre eux le retour d'harry
aujourd'hui en fait les partis sunnites
donc le parti de rire est lui même le
parti de mikati les partis chiites amal
et hezbollah soutiennent sa candidature
mais sa candidature ne fait pas donc
l'unanimité parce que tous les députés
du mont liban
c'est à dire essentiellement les partis
chrétiens et les parties druzes se
reposent en fait à la nomination de saad
hariri et la rue bien sûr qui s'opposent
à lui
aujourd'hui en fait il paraît difficile
de faire fait de faire d'amener qu'elle
une autre personnalité que lui parce que
en fait il ya comme je vous ai dit c'est
parti qui contrôle tout le système
il y a un an le 17 octobre
le liban connaissait voilà cette
première vague de révolte un mouvement
populaire
à travers le pays qu'est ce qui a manqué
à cette révolution qui stagne
aujourd'hui est ce que le fait qu'il n'y
ait pas véritablement de leader à cette
révolte populaire voilà fait que les
choses n'avancent pas finalement oui
tout à fait en fait la révolution c'est
une sorte de mouvement des grévistes
comme on a pu en voir en fait en europe
et ailleurs est en fête et oui
effectivement ils n'ont pas pu se doter
d'un leader ils n'ont pas pu se doter
d'un projet commun en fait il ya des
mêmes des projets qui sont complètement
opposés les uns des autres
vous avez des groupes qui sont proches
des frères musulmans à tripoli vous avez
des mêmes des groupes proches de lobby
lgbt à beyrouth mais vous avez aussi
quand même des groupes qui qui ont des
idées en commun mais qui sont juste en
train de s'affronter en fait sur une
question de leadership justement alors
que ni les uns ni les autres n'ont pu
s'imposer dans le débat crise économique
pour le libor on nous parle également
voilà de crise politique et d'épidémies
de coronavirus qu'elle est aujourd'hui
l'urgence pour les libanais bien sûr
l'urgence elle est économique et
financière aujourd'hui on parle de 55%
de libanais vivant sous le seuil de
pauvreté en principe d'ici la fin de
l'année ce taux pourrait atteindre 75%
vous avez la banque centrale n'a
quasiment plus de rezé de réserve vont
de vie c'est-à-dire de réserves en
dollars et ne pourra puis bientôt plus
acheter de médicaments de fioul de
doubler et du coup les la population
risque de sombrer encore plus dans la
misère c'est pour ça qu'il est vraiment
très important de former un gouvernement
même si en plus on ne peut pas avoir le
gouvernement que l'on souhaite mais afin
en fait de pouvoir accéder aux fonds de
la communauté internationale c'est à
dire les fonds de la conférence aids qui
s'était tenue à paris en 2018 est
également les fonds prévus par le fmi
qui doit être négocié avec le fmi
parce que le gouvernement sortant
démissionnaire avait négocié un plan qui
était donc accepté par le fmi mais qui
avaient été bloqués par le parlement par
la banque centrale et par l'association
des banques et comme emmanuel macron l'a
dit il n'ya pas d'autre alternative que
ce plan est ce plan et il est important
de l'appliquer pour pouvoir accéder à
ces fonds du fmi et de la conférence
aids
merci beaucoup michel fayyad d'avoir
voilà accepté notre invitation pour
parler de cette situation au liban je
rappelle que vous êtes analyste aux
politiques et financiers